Good morning, John!
Welcome to Games with Hank!
So a few years ago, I started HankGames, because
I'm Hank and I like games!
And when you said "Hey, I wanna come and also
play video games on HankGames," I was totally
into that idea!
And frankly, what you do at John Plays FIFA,
where there are these fictional soccer players,
who have a life together and are raising a
child and both happen to be named John Green,
while simultaneously raising actual money
for the ACTUAL team that exists in the REAL
life, SO MUCH money that in fact, now, Nerdfighteria's
logos are on the uniforms of that team!
THAT'S A REALLY COOL THING, and I don't wanna
take away from that.
But the thing I wanna do is different, and
I wanna upload a new Games with Hank episode
every single day of the week forever, and
I feel like it's different enough that I wanted
to start a whole new channel dedicated to
it, so THAT is what Games with Hank is!
We're starting out Games with Hank experimenting
with this.
This is the Oculus Rift, you put it on your
face.
You basically, suddenly, are in a new world.
Anybody who has spent any amount of time with
the Oculus comes out of the experience thinking
"Oh my God!
Everything's gonna change!"
It's completely different, from any other
media experience I have ever experienced.
I'm starting out on Games with Hank with three
days of me playing a horror game.
HERE'S A COUPLE OF CLIPS FROM THAT.
Hank while playing: A nice house, with frien-
OOOHAHA, oh jeez, oh jeez, oh jeez, fart,
fart, fart, see, this is nice..
Space, lots of room, the furniture's floating.
Play the.. play the music.
AAAAAAHHH!!!
It's difficult to convey how scary this is!
When I take the Oculus off at the end of the
game, I'm like "Oh, right, I'm here!"
These virtual communities that have become
very real to me, I know that it just happens
on the computer screen, it's clearly not a
physical space, but the human condition is
that things occur in physical space, so if
things are occurring, we sort of apply physical
space to them, but we don't do a great job
of it.
But this COULD do a great job of that.
Now the really weird thing about all of this
is that physical spaces tend to change very
slowly; that's not the case on the internet.
Youtube changes its design and suddenly I
feel like somebody just redesigned my whole
house!
Why did you do that?!
I had a house, and I knew where the bathroom
was, and now I don't, and I'm like "Where
is the bathroom?!
WHERE DID YOU PUT THE BATHROOM?!"
That's an uncomfortable feeling!
Now in Games with Hank, we're gonna be playing
video games with the Oculus and other kinds
of video games, of course.
But the clear potential once you put this
thing on is so much greater than that for
the future of all kinds of entertainment,
for the future of sports, of art, of education,
of music, of exploration, of adventure, of
medicine, of politics!
I know that I'm extra excited right now because
I've just experienced something that is really
weird and different, so probably take this
with a grain of salt: but holy crap, man!
I think, what we're gonna have to be ready
for, is a lot of people saying how this is
going to destroy civilization, and a lot of
people saying how it's going to save civilization,
but here's my stellar prediction: neither
of those people are gonna be right.
Just like the internet, it's gonna be a mixed
bag, but it IS going to change things!
And I also will make NO predictions for how
it will actually be used!
People will try LOTS of things!
And some of those things will be extraordinarily
amazing and will resonate with what it is
to be human.
As you could tell, pretty excited about it.
TWO QUICK UPDATES!
First, John, your punishment: I've decided
that you should get a tattoo!
But I know you don't wanna get a tattoo, so
instead, you're gonna get a tattoo without
any ink in the gun!
It's just gonna hurt a lot, and you won't
have anything to show for it.
Second, Vlogbrothers has had prerolls on it
for over a month now, which means that we
have a big pile of cash that we're distributing
to awesome creators!
One of those creators is Youtube's Physics
Girl, who we're giving an equipment grant
to!
And the other is Kelly Kend, who's working
on a documentary about consent and sexual
assault.
Kelly's documentary raised $10,000 on Kickstarter,
which she spent all of already working on
the film.
I found her stuff, I reached out to her and
I said "Here's some of Nerdfighteria's money,"
she's very excited about it.
I did a little interview with her and I'll
put it up on Hankschannel.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
I mean, I really think if you remodeled this
place it could be quite nice.
You might want to instead just wanna burn
it to the ground, though, if you have the
option.